Tim had me Randy put you on blast all
over Vaughn look at Buster's tongue I
own this man time for a sneaker
venture my dude your Stang shoe game is
messing with our reps
yeah even free lunch Libre was clowning
you he wears cleats to school no
tripping my star buries his vintage
Popeye Jones rock these I that's it show
him Jamal City retweeted Randy's video
my neck and she also left her coming
damn smiley face with tears that's
messed up
maybe it is time for a change this
year's Sun double-a-c-p
Image Awards are brought to you by
chuckles Footwear
I gotcha
ha gosh
shackles they're off the chain oh
that's it my niggas that's how i'ma get
my street credit bag I got a cop me some
Shack
[Music]